when Apple Engineers pitched Steve Jobs
on turning the iPod into an iPhone he
responded why the F would we want to do
that that is the dumbest idea I've ever
heard reported Adam Grant in his book
think again jobs feared creating a phone
would undermine the iPod which sold 20
million units in 2005 and accounted for
nearly half of Apple's Revenue that year
besides jobs thought a phone would only
appeal to the pocket protector crowd he
was also concerned that mobile phone
carriers would dictate the iPhone design
and features and force Apple to make a
subpar product but those who wanted an
Apple phone refused to give up Tony
fidell who headed the team that built
the iPod told Adam grant that in order
to convince jobs people had to work as a
group not simply in one meeting but
possibly over weeks to get him to change
his mind or to see things from Another
angle contrary to popular belief Steve
Jobs wasn't a success solely because he
bent the world to his vision much of his
success had to do with the willingness
to change his mind and his team knew how
to get him to do that before the iPhone
just about everyone in apple thought
cell phones sucked jobs was known to
smash his to bits when his calls dropped
but pitching to jobs wasn't as simple as
saying wouldn't it be awesome of Apple
built a phone everyone loved using it
involves strategically chipping away at
his Resistance 2 years before presenting
the iPhone concept to jobs a small group
of Apple's designers and Engineers
experimented with new ways of
interfacing with machines they stumbled
upon a small Delaware company
fingerworks co-founded by PhD student
and his Professor who built a touchpad
that interacted directly with the screen
Apple would eventually acquire
fingerworks and its patents related to
finger gestures the Apple team aspired
to expand Beyond a touchpad to a full
touchscreen perhaps for a device like a
tablet Apple designer Imran chowri
explained to Brian merchin in his book
The One device we want to be able to
move things on the the screen like a
piece of paper on the table they worked
in stealth mode worried that if jobs
found out about it and didn't like it
the whole thing could get clashed after
showing the multi-touch demo to Apple's
chief designer Johnny IV who had job ear
IV told the team this is going to change
everything but he was careful to show it
to jobs privately because of his
tendency to dismiss ideas out of hand
I've explained to Walter Isaacson in his
biography on jobs he might say this is
sh and snuff the idea I feel that ideas
are very fragile so you have to be
tender when they in development I
realized that if you pissed on this it
would be so sad because I knew it was so
important after mulling it over for a
few days he agreed touch was the future
but he was still not sold on a
phone yet other phones on the market
began to threaten the iPod with their
ability to play music like Nokia's music
phones Apple then decided to partner
with Motorola to incorporate the iPod
into a new Motorola cell phone and it's
pretty cool phone well actually The
Rocker was neither minimalistic like the
iPod nor slim like Motorola's popular
razor it was such a disaster that Wired
Magazine lamented on its cover you call
this the phone of the future putting
iPod features into a Motorola phone just
seemed ass backwards to me recalled
Apple Senior executive Mike Bell and
merch's book Belle was one of those who
had Lobby jobs to build an Apple phone
for months in November 20 2004 he
emailed jobs late at night Steve I know
you don't want to do a phone but here's
why we should do it Johnny I has some
really cool designs for future iPods
that no one has seen we ought to take
one of those put some Apple software
around it and make a phone out of it
ourselves instead of putting our stuff
on other people's phones jobs called him
and they argued for hours Belle pointed
out it was only a matter of time before
computers music players and cell phones
converged the team believed that if they
made the product compelling enough they
could influence mobile carriers to adopt
Apple's terms for design software and
distribution finally jobs relented
telling Belle okay I think we should go
do it they considered two different
versions of the iPhone the first one was
modeled after the iPod but the scroll
wheel made it tough to dial phone
numbers jobs humorously added an
outdated rotary dial to the mockup to
show the limitations of that design the
second option was multi-touch which was
more akin to a mini computer jobs was
convinced touch was the way forward
selecting the material for the iPhone's
touchcreen was another major hurdle just
four months before jobs planed to reveal
the iPhone to the world he decided to
switch the screen from plastic to Glass
because plastic was too easily scratched
Engineers were in a frenzy because they
knew they had to find a glass
replacement that could pass the 1 meter
drop test and so far all the prototypes
had failed a friend of job suggested he
reach out to Wendell weeks the CEO of
cing an American glassware company that
had once prototyped a strong scratch
proof product dubbed Gorilla Glass but
didn't have a market for it when they
met jobs doubted the glass was good
enough and started lecturing weeks on
how glass was made weeks boldly
interjected as described in isaacson's
book can you shut up and let me teach
you some science in the end jobs was
convinced but then week said his company
didn't have the capacity to make Gilla
glass at its factories to which job said
don't be afraid yes you can do it get
your mind around it you can do it and
Corning did do it weeks told Isaacson we
did it in under 6 months we produced a
glass that had never been made the day
the iPhone came out job sent weeks a
message that's now framed in his office
we couldn't have done it without
you and we are calling
it
iPhone
today today apple is going to reinvent
the phone when jobs unveiled the iPhone
to the world in January 2007 it lacked a
key feature the original iPhone had no
external apps it was limited to Apple's
pre-installed apps there was no app
store jobs was worried that a poorly
written third-party app would cause the
iPhone to crash especially in critical
situations where someone might need to
call 911 however Scott Forstall head of
the iPhone software division saw the
potential of a rich app ecosystem he
told jobs that they could isolate and
manage any security risks the push for
thirdparty apps wasn't just internal
developers were advocating for an open
platform and they got it what we call
the App Store Apple officially launched
the App Store in the summer of 2008
allowing third-party apps immediately
pushed iPhone sales through the roof 4
years after it launch the iPhone made up
nearly half of Apple's total revenue and
it still accounts for half of Apple's
Revenue
today with well over 2 billion iPhones
sold tech industry analyst and apple
expert hor stenda put the stunning
success of the iPhone this way the
iPhone is not only the bestselling
mobile phone but also the bestselling
music player the bestselling camera the
bestselling video screen and the
bestselling computer of all time it is
quite simple simply the bestselling
product of all time all because Steve
Jobs was willing to change his mind
Steve Jobs changed his mind about
building the iPhone because he thought
like a scientist he had the flexibility
to reconsider his views when presented
with compelling arguments if you're
looking to sharpen your problem solving
skills and develop a scientific approach
to thinking I highly recommend brilliant
brilliant is a website and app where you
can brush up on your math computer
science and data science skills
interactively and it's free for you to
try out in brilliant scientific thinking
course you can explore the laws of
physics and the principles of
engineering by solving interactive
puzzles I like to take 10 to 15 minutes
every day to go through brilliant's
logic puzzles which I find have improved
my analytical thinking brilliant is
great whether you're starting out on
your stem Journey or want to improve on
what you already know you can try out
brilliant for free by heading to the
custom link in my description
brilliant.org SL news think if you're
one of the first 200 people to sign up
with my link you'll receive 20% off your
premium subscription giving you full
access to a world of knowledge thanks
for watching for news think I'm Cindy
pal